hi
um i'm
really really really really really
excited today because today i am going
to be showing you something that is so
freaking exciting that i honestly just
like i can't contain myself and this
right here
is a lightsaber bag and inside of here
is the ij
series lightsaber
i'm gonna show them to you there's three
versions and i did this collaboration
with imperial sabres and i've got a
bunch of their sabers before so now it's
time for the big reveal i'm so hyped you
guys may have seen our short film that
we did that was basically a very quick
video we shot that sunrise to sunset in
one day in hawaii i edited on the flight
back and here we are we're launching
this thing and i'm so excited to show it
to you so when you do purchase an ij
series lightsaber you also get one of
these bags with it now prepare yourself
yes okay so here they are this is two of
them now there's three we have a black a
silver
and a gold so the cool thing about this
is it is modular so you can take off
all of these various pieces and you can
kind of make this however you want it
and why this is so cool is this is the
configuration that i like for combat
because this protects your fingers and
it's really great because if you're
you're in you know battle and another
saber hits you
i guess if this was actual real life
real star wars
you probably would just get your whole
hand sliced in half but we're talking
about real life not like real real you
know what i mean if you hit this
like your hand is not gonna get smashed
and let me tell you what i've had my
finger smashed way too many times
when sparring with these also i guess
hold on a second there's a really good
chance some of you might be confused or
like justine i thought you just do tuck
unboxing i don't know what's happening
right now why do you have a lightsaber
so for the past year my friends i guess
it's not that secret of a hobby but i
have been training a few various martial
arts over the past couple of years but
specifically over the past year i
started getting into lightsaber combat
and my trainer here in los angeles he
knows a bunch of different martial arts
but we were most specifically we started
training kali which is usually with like
two weapons it's like a filipino martial
arts and we kind of started out with
knives and sticks and then one day he's
like hey we should do this with
lightsabers and i was like why didn't
you mention this day one that we started
training so ever since then i've been
kind of going down this whole lightsaber
path and it is a crazy world out there i
just want to show you this is the first
lightsaber that i have purchased
i've bought five or six or maybe
actually seven of these and this thing
is absolutely destroyed now i just also
this is not the company that i have
partnered with i am showing you what a
poor quality lightsaber looks like to
show you what a good quality lightsaber
looks like so this plastic saber is
not good it's super low quality it's
very thin we were able to do a little
bit of combat with these but honestly
i've gone through at least eight of
these and this one was maybe like 150
like almost 200 for this little piece of
garbage that barely worked the entire
insides of it is just like inset inside
of it and it's just not good fast
forward to a trip to hawaii to oahu that
i went to in august and i met this guy
nate and he's absolutely incredible and
he trains at a ufc gym out of kailua in
oahu so if you're ever there like you
gotta go you gotta go check it out take
one of the classes so anyway he is in
partnership with imperial sabres who
makes these lightsabers anyway i trained
with him and then i bought a few of the
imperial sabers and i absolutely loved
them and what i love so much about them
is how durable they are first of all
like this this is freaking quality like
you can go out to battle with your
friends your enemies and you guys can
actually
you can
not
not like you can just freaking go out
and just do it oh yeah these do turn on
by the way
uh there's various different settings
that you can
change
let me turn this off real quick and
there's a little card that it comes with
and gives you the instructions on how to
use this so this little light will light
up as you press
and that
corresponds
with all of the various settings so it's
actually a little bright here in my
studio but you can change the saber
light to pulsates i prefer this kind of
like just standard
just a standard saber light it also has
sounds
and there is even music
and various
sound effects i'll show you
the dark side
you can change the color um which is
pretty exciting
so i'm going to go i've got a yellow you
basically can change it to any color
like this cycles through and then you
press the button
and then that'll lock in your color and
it's really cool because like i am now
sort of like in this whole lightsaber
universe and there's so many things that
i didn't realize a lot of lightsaber
companies charge extra for every single
little tiny thing if you want to mute
your lightsaber that's extra if you want
to have different colors that's extra so
i was so excited to find out that like
when you buy one of these yes they are
expensive but honestly the amount of
really crappy lightsabers that i have
gone through
to get here
is
just is honestly so exciting because
this is actually really incredible
quality and one of the things that i
love about the ij series saber is how
amazing it is for spinning so there's
like this little piece right here that
is also this is all modular so all of
these pieces do come off and so this is
where your little light is
and that just hooks onto here now what's
cool about this for spinning is it's a
perfect weight if you're interested in
doing any type of lightsaber spinning so
it's like your hand just rests like
perfectly right here and it makes it
very easy to spin it's also an
incredible weight like the weight
balance between the blade and the hilt
these are things that when i first
bought a couple random lightsabers off
of amazon i had
no idea what i was getting into and now
that i do know what i'm looking for it's
here this is this is it
and imperial savers has such a huge wide
variety that it's kind of overwhelming
but i'm so hyped about this because i
love the fact that it is a perfect way
for spinning and then also
we've got some accessories i'm going to
show you guys how this all
works and to charge it it's just a
little usb you plug this right into here
it lasts a pretty long time as well so
as you can see this has the little disc
on it
for your protective combat needs and
this comes with a little bag like this
and you'll get a little tool just like
that so there's these little screws
right there so that's how you put your
blade in so to turn this into the combat
version we just
screw this on just like so
put on our hilt and that
my friends
is how
we go to war
here's both the black and the silver
that are now all set for combat and i'll
show you how easy it is to attach a
blade to this so this is what one of the
new blades looks like it is wrapped very
nicely just like this
and it's
so
satisfying
you'll get the little disc accessory
and you'll get a blade so the blade just
slides right in and then you've got
these little tiny screws that you're
gonna just screw right into place and so
what i did for this because this does
add on a little bit of length to the
blade
and it will put like a little i guess
like a little screw mark into it so i
like to set this blade up first with the
length of this piece and then i could
just easily screw this one on and off to
add on very easily if i want to switch
it to a combat type situation so yeah
just uh screw that in just like
that and if i want to add on
hit the little disc obviously i do love
the other two colors as well but you
guys know that i'm a huge gold fan like
hello accessories accessorizing so
here they are this is what all three of
them look like and you might notice in
the little trailer that we did there was
another blade and this is called a
ripper blade this is actually
handmade so they don't have very many of
these available so these are all
like custom etched ins so they don't
have very many of these so if you do
want to add on one of these blades that
is an option but just note this is
extremely limited but it's so cool
because this is all like chromed out and
this black is
just etched in and it's actually pretty
impressive because we did a lot of
sparring with this and it held up really
really well so this is kind of what a
brand new blade looks like very smooth
very sleek and this
i don't even know if you can tell but
this is one of our
very heavily used blades they are
incredibly durable and these also do
have a year warranty if anything were to
go wrong you guys can contact them and
they will help you resolve your issues
now they will take a little while to
ship so if you do end up ordering these
there's a really good chance if you're
watching this right now it is around the
holidays you might not get it there in
time for christmas but if you do order
one i made a little video that you can
send to your friend or your family
member or whoever you got one of these
for and it's like a personalized little
thing that says hey your friend sent you
one of these might not make it in time
for the holidays but
stay tuned in the mail because it'll be
there there's also something that's
really exciting about this whole kind of
little endeavor is imperial sabres also
has this other sort of side separate
company called savoration where they do
competitive tournaments with lightsaber
combat and it's so freaking cool they
have classes all around the world and my
new friend nate who i met in oahu who i
told you guys about we actually made a
little video while i was on the big
island he flew in to help me make that
little cinematic trailer and we also
filmed some tutorials because there's so
much that kind of goes into this that i
didn't even know about so in addition to
getting the sabres we're also going to
give you access to this little ij army
membership community that will give you
some spinning basics and also the
various forms there's like form one
through seven which shows you like the
different techniques in each form so we
wanted to kind of give you that as a
little added bonus so if you do get one
of these you can be started on your
lightsaber journey i mean you can also
just get this as like a really cool prop
piece but i expect you guys to go out
and use these like yeah it looks cool
but i want to see you guys spinning and
doing cool stuff like i am very very
early in my journey in this art form so
i still have a very long way to go but
it is such a fun activity and it's
something that you really don't need a
training partner for like you can start
doing these spinning techniques and
learning a lot of different stuff online
like there's so many different classes
that you can take and even on imperial
sabers they have a link that you can
actually enroll in their curriculum
they've got all sorts of classes and
maybe even you can take like a real life
class one day it's just so much fun and
it's like this whole other world that i
didn't know existed and now that i know
that it does i
think if you guys have been around for a
while you know that when i get into
things like i'm i'm in like i'm so
all in like i'm dedicated i'm so
dedicated that we freaking came out with
an ij series lightsaber so if you
haven't watched episode one of the ij
series i'll put a link in the
description to check it out if you guys
want more information about these sabers
or if you want to buy one all of the
links again will be in the description
i'm super hyped about this so i hope you
guys are excited too so now that i
showed you guys the sabers we're gonna
go cut to a little clip here with nate
who is talking kind of about imperial
sabers and why we both really love this
specific lightsaber design and yeah so
here we go let's let's go to hawaii hey
guys it's justine and i'm here with nate
hi guys i am so excited that you're here
can you do like a little introduction
for sure yeah buddy so yeah i'm uh with
the imperial sabres as well as the
savoration company we make our own
lightsabers plus we also teach
lightsabers to competitions so that we
can compete with them so not just play
with them but actually use them as a
sport and i had no idea that this whole
world existed like i just started
getting into doing like lightsaber
combat just sort of by accident and then
i randomly
met you on oahu when we were filming
something with sony i had one of my
lightsabers just sitting off to the side
and toby our sound guy was like oh my
friend actually trains at the ufc gym
with like lightsabers like no you call
him right now get his info and then we
trained in oahu and long story short
we're here now with the ij series
lightsabers so this is two of the colors
that we have this is the gold this is
the black and then there's a silver one
and we went out and we filmed like a
really cool little short film but you've
been doing martial arts and this kind of
stuff for so long so like how did you
kind of get into this and what is your
background i started in kaiota when i
was very little like about eight years
old and that was also a little bit jiu
jitsu as well but now i'm teaching ji
kundo and jigano is very eclectic it has
so many different martial arts in it and
i've also done stunts and films so
kind of on both sides of real fighting
and also
fake fighting which is more for fun and
also for uh making it look good right so
that's what we like to do with these
sabers too we also compete with them
which is kind of more realistic but
sport we also kind of play with them too
to make them more like choreography or
fancier having fun with uh making it
look cool put a link in the description
where you guys can get these savers and
you can also check out nate on social
media because he's got so many cool tick
tocks and i'm just i'm so excited you're
here like this is incredible thank you
very much for making me for allowing
this to happen
amazing for me too i really didn't watch
i loved justine's work and when she was
doing sabers i was like wow okay i mean
we could do something with this now and
you've done a bunch of youtube stuff
also with like devin supertrip yes
that's right so this is youtube family
here you guys all know devon and his
incredible stuff because you were in a
couple of hours have you ever seen the
parkour
dinosaur or like when we did the real
life um jurassic park so there's that
one and uh we just did one recently for
a state of survival if you guys are
having a wahoo you should definitely
check out the ufc gym in kailua and take
a lightsaber class with nate because
it's honestly it's so much fun you know
the whole sport aspect and you guys even
have with the savoration like there's a
fitness aspect of this as well so
there's three of us it's me who does the
sport the combat and the um competition
part of it and there's nick who does a
saber fit and then there's edward who
got together lightsabers created all
these partners with us so it was our
main brain basically he's like the
overhead everything and he created all
the curriculum and he's partnered with
us so that we could do the individual
pieces so like nick does the saber fit i
do mostly the competition and martial
art teaching of the lightsaber but he
controls the other stuff like like the
online curriculum that's how it goes wow
like i can't believe it and i'm really
excited about the saber because you had
told me about the imperial sabers so
then i went and bought one and then i
added another one into my cart and then
i ended up with three of them and then i
got combat gloves so i basically like
got the whole setup out of the three
that i picked some of them were a little
bit too heavy for me for spinning and i
was like this is a beautiful saber but
this saber is the ij series and i'm so
excited about this one because for
spinning and even for like combat it's
so light but it also has kind of this
what would you call this piece is there
like a specific name for it uh that's
the uh emitter basically so this is part
of the emitter this is the uh the shaft
of the blade and there's the pummel we
talked about this in the saber uh
teaching as well how to divide up the
blades like any weapon right in martial
arts you have like different parts of
the blade that are different for
different reasons like i'm so excited
about this because like for spinning and
stuff like that like this just feels
so perfect and the weight of it and the
balance like everything about it i was
like this is it like i absolutely love
it and it's so cool because on even the
website like there are so many
customizations that you guys can do like
it was wild i was so overwhelmed i think
i spent like four hours going through
and just like looking at different ones
i don't know i'm just so excited that
this all worked out and you're here and
we made a really cool short film but
again i'll put a link in the description
where you guys can check this out and
you can check out savoration and
imperial sabers and nate and nick and
edward and the whole crew and i'm so
honored though to be a part of this now
like this is so exciting thank you so
much i'm really honored to be here as
well so it's really fun for me to come
out here and train with you i'm working
hard i'm gonna i'm gonna get better i'm
a jedi in training